في المستقبل ، قد ينطوي ارتداء الملابس
على الكثير من التكنولوجيا أكثر مما كنت تتوقعه في أي وقت مضى ،
لذلك هذا هو المكان الذي تعرف أنه يمكنك
أن ترى فيه جودة الصورة الواقعية حقًا
على الرغم من أنها ثلاثية الأبعاد
، أرى الفراء وكأنه يتحرك أولاً إلى أعلى
مظهر صدى أمازون يسمونه مساعد الأناقة
لذلك قمنا باختبارها على
أليكسا أليكسا ، التقط صورة مقابل
مصمم أزياء حقيقي هناك ، نذهب
بمظهر ديكو لتعقب النمط الخاص به ، والذي يحاكي ما
يفعله المصمم الفعلي ، لذلك عندما ترى
هذا الزي ، فأنت تعرف ما الذي يدور في
ذهنك ،
دعونا نتظاهر بريان  بأنني ذاهب
إلى حفلة أحد الأصدقاء ، حسنًا ، لا أعرف
السبب ولكن أليكسا لا تعرف ما
الذي نحاول القيام به ولكن
أيهما تفضله ، فإن الدانتيل
يشبه لمسة تفاصيل ليلية لطيفة
الفستان الذي أعتقد أنه سيعمل بشكل أفضل ،
لكن يبدو ليليًا أكثر بالتأكيد ،
دعونا نجري فحصًا للأناقة ، تستغرق المراجعة
بعض الوقت ، ولكن عندما يتم ذلك ، فإنه يصنف
أي الفستان هو الأفضل
- أليكسا من المفترض أن
أرتدي اللون الأزرق الفاتح  زي النهار جيدًا
يقولون إن الألوان تراهن على أن شكل الزي يناسبك
بشكل أفضل ، لكن عندما
تسمع عن تطور كل هذه
التقنيات المتقدمة ، هل تقلق
بشأن مستقبل وظيفتك بالنسبة لي ، فأنا
شخصيًا لا أعتقد ذلك معك.
أعتقد أن مستقبل التكنولوجيا والموضة
سيستفيد مثل الإنتاج
والبيع بالتجزئة كمصمم ، فهناك فقط
أنك تعرف التواصل بين الأشخاص
الذي لا يمكنك استبداله إذا أراد RN VR
تغيير طريقة تسوقنا للصور الرمزية الرقمية
بحاجة إلى الظهور والتحرك مثل
البشر  ابتكر باحثون من معهد ماكس
بلانك للأنظمة الذكية
غطاءً من القماش يلتقط كيفية
تحرك الملابس على الصورة الرمزية الرقمية ،
ويمكنه أيضًا تقدير كيفية ظهور الملابس على
أنواع الجسم المختلفة التي ستمر سنوات
قبل أن نتسوق في غرف نومنا في
الواقع المعزز والواقع الافتراضي ولكن  التكنولوجيا تزداد
ذكاءً ، لذا فإن أسلوبك المفضل